let's bring in the Clemson linebacker
Ben congratulations how much sleep have
you gotten in the last couple of nights
not not a lot honestly after the game we
got back to the hotel
around 2:30 and we wouldn't hang out
hung out in the lobby for our - and I
got in bed final 4 or 4:30 and I wanted
to sleep but man I was hurting I was
that's probably the most so I've ever
been in my entire life I mean they
obviously the whole world knows how big
Alabama and how physical they are and I
felt that firsthand after that game so I
did not sleep at all after the game late
in bed till about 7:00 and then we'll
just kind of when God made a little
bathtub in my hotel room and got in the
hot tub and I wore my bedroom and I was
up eating breakfast on eight and then I
had the most to split the first sleep I
got was I want a better on 9:30 last
night and currently at my house and
Anderson sitting in my pole a little
homemade ice tub in my underwear now
doing this interview freezing my butt
off can you take my picture back right
Ben can you take a picture and and tweet
it to us so we can show people you know
absolutely I can yeah absolutely
absolutely I'm expressing source and the
homemade ice tub I'll see y'all fetcher
why why was it so violent I know you
know you're playing for a national title
but how did it become more violent or
painful than another big game I mean
because Alabama
I mean Alabama's who they are for a
reason they have their dynasty and they
have their brand because of the success
the success they've earned over the past
couple years on how talent how talented
and physical they are and you also
experience that firsthand with it all
the line
beau Scarborough I mean they're just a
freaks out there I mean I've gone soft
but Scarborough one time we obviously
try to slow him down or a lot of the
game he had us two big run
and I almost had to tackle off on them
one time and completely just bounce off
them they're just their big dudes they
recruit as good as anybody in the
country and it's just downhill old
school physical football which I love
doing I love those type of games what
the side effects and the aftermath after
the game sucks that's why I'm and my
pole hunt house I feel like crap when
did you know the severity of above
scarborough's injury when he broke a
bone in his leg I didn't know till after
the game we're on the bus and they said
that he broke his leg because he liked
what he said when I saw when he he got
up after the hit and he has walked a
couple steps and then he laid back down
and appreciate he walked off the field
so I'm pretty sure I mean I think the
tough dudes a big dude I'm sure he could
have played he could have played prices
a lot of the game with a broken leg I
mean I saw him walk off the field he
honestly went felt good and he wouldn't
admit us as useful with a normal leg I'm
sure he could have played through it I'm
sure that he wanted to be on that field
but his staff and the coaches that
hadn't had to keep them all armed I'm
sure it wasn't that big of a like a
break I don't honestly know the severity
of it but to see him walk off the field
I'm sure he could play through it that
the staff will let him he said Ben bull
where the Clemson linebacker joining us
Dan Patrick show take me into halftime
what does coach say to you when it
looked like Alabama could have been up
by a couple of touchdowns and maybe
three right yeah it was definitely
looking very grim on the first quarter
after those two big plays we gave up
but coach 20 was just calm preaching to
us this is near zero it's a whole new
ball game
on these next two quarters and just
leave it on the line for the seniors
it's the last game y'all ever play in a
Clinton uniform
so just exhaust a moment and you get it
give it all for your brother and your
teammate and that's what we did says the
third and fourth quarter we found a way
to win not a lot of but grabbing on
Monday night they're been what changed
in the game plan for the Tigers
that's not never really in the game plan
being Christian just were just messing
around
honest we knew that the media attention
would be over all of
that if we did it again so that's not
something I'll ever do again or a
Christian you're really just trying to
have fun out there but yeah that's
something will will stray away from for
our rest of our careers how surprised
were you that that got so big so quick I
don't know I really don't want to talk
about how much I kind of want to just
put that in the past I was honestly just
being Christian trying to have fun out
there and just break up the seriousness
of the game so I mean yes it is what it
is it happened we're just weird honestly
just messing around something that it's
not who we are honestly so it wasn't our
game plan so some people we won't do it
again just were just try one mess around
there
what was the scouting report on Jalen
Hurd's
there is a very talented athlete we knew
going to the game that he was very
athletic
very good with the ball in his hands but
we knew if we limited their running
games obviously everyone knows that they
focused an entire offense on pounding
the rock every single snap yeah they can
do that at opens up the passing game for
them which is difficult we know that he
we make him sit in the pocket and make a
lot of deep throws that he'll be a
difficult night for them nothing that's
what we wanted to do we obviously gave
up a couple big running plays that we
obviously wish we could take back but
other than that I feel like we would
completely dominated on third down we
slowed them down for the most part and
made them uncomfortable in the pocket
from most the game I'm gonna showed he
honestly we know these are great athlete
we know if we kept in the pocket make it
made him uncomfortable they'd have a
difficult time beating us in the passing
game so I don't feel like for the most
part we did that how much trash talking
was going on not much really at all no I
really wasn't for the first couple plays
I mean you talked a little bit that's
just football no one takes it to heart
for a lot of the game it was all respect
out there a lot of the players came
Robinson came to me and shook my hand
after that after the game
so the respects there was the whole game
we knew how talented both teams were
we're also gonna run your mouth a little
just because it's football and that just
happens in the game but for the most
part we really we wasn't much talking
going on but one there was talking I was
honestly just a normal conversation
nothing too serious or not not much
trash talk
Alabama recruit you they started to they
wanted me my senior year I think my
junior senior years come up visit for a
game or some junior day or something
like that um but before I came up there
where I was I was definitely going to
entertain that as a libero alabama there
they had that brand but before I went up
there it's going to go up there close it
off my scholarship and I thought of sue
the place I've always wanted to go um so
I went when they offered me I didn't
feel like putting on a show for Alabama
and act like I was gonna entertain their
scholarship when I had to Clemson on the
board so when it closed it offered
obviously jump on that so that there
obviously wasn't they weren't one of the
first schools to recruit me but they
started to a little bit I think it was
their deal on coach I'm not sure what
his name was I think he actually coached
at Clemson a little bit he was my
recruiter from Alabama but it wasn't too
serious do you do an impersonation of
your coach I get asked a lot and I'm not
very good at it
I've really wished I had J : though with
me he obviously is the the guy on the
team is that it's really good with
impersonations he can do a lot of people
and I don't want to let anyone down
because I'm not that funny of a guy and
it will be a terrible impersonation I
really wish y'all get jiggler him on the
show and he will light it up it'll be
perfect and y'all die laughing J Glenn
was the man one of my best friends I'll
love him to death
you need to talk to Jay glory Mon he
will do a spot-on impersonation sorry to
let you down the mine stuck and it won't
be funny at all you got talked to Jay
are you planning on playing in the NFL
and that's the plan that's definitely
been a dream of mine my entire life I
feel like I have what it takes to be
successful in the next level I feel like
what I put on film the past three years
is up there with the best so yeah that's
definitely the dream and I feel like I
have the tape that matches up with that
why number 10 I wanted a low number just
I feel like low numbers were cool Ayanna
just like nice like you know I'm gonna
low no but I don't want to really do
like 54 or like a 45 on defense that's
kind of like old school so I just wanted
to have a low number I honestly felt was
cool and my only options going in we're
number one and number one number ten
thou are open for defense and I asked
coach venimos I could be number one here
just like hell no you're not a one I
guess for life prima donnas like dislike
their sassy or sissies like that's not
your you're not number one all right
dang it I won't be able to watch geez
Louise so I picked them or ten and
honestly Ty's definitely started that
number started that trend so there are a
lot of number 10 judges out there when I
took that role over so a lot of the ten
judges that are out there now are
probably still for ties um religious
because they're those were only two
options if I won the low number and
coach P would not want to get number one
uh so yeah that's that story
have you ever hit deshaun Watson
absolutely not
that is yeah that's a recipe for
disaster
if you hit Shawn in practice coach 20
would pull your scholarship and kick you
off the team probably he is off-limits
as is all the other quarterbacks on our
team honestly everyone knows how
important quarterbacks are after
football and then they're there's only a
couple of them on the team and Shawn is
who yes I mean if someone hit him on I
kind of like I was I was blitzing like
one time to yummers two years ago I was
blitzing like a team period and I bliss
them and I tried to swipe at his hand
and knock the ball out I hit his hand I
kind of hurt his finger
coach sweet use my tail and talk off the
field he legit almost kicked me out of
practice cuz I hit him I literally I hit
his finger and he like kicked me off the
field like wouldn't let me practice for
like a period or two cause I was just
college doing like I was like one my
mouth like hit a bunch of players I just
I was young like I didn't know how to
know how to practice I was full speed
the whole time just being an idiot and I
hit his finger and coach 20 ripped my
tail and that is kind of how it is for
everyone else
oh you got one that you get to hit him
Knicks are in the NFL
oh yeah and I've been waiting on that
for four years now I get the opportunity
I promise you if I get that opportunity
to suplex them like a Syracuse it I
promise you I'll do it and I'll give him
a big hug after kissing cheek cuz I love
them but I had to wait four years to hit
them so if I get the opportunity next
year you best believe I won't let it
pass up
make sure you tweet that picture out
we'll share it with our audience and
congrats and good luck in your future
Ben thank you yes yes I appreciate that
that's been Boulware clemson linebacker
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]